Not too long ago, the internet was abuzz with news that the ferocious Tyrannosaurus Rex was
as many news agencies put it, a sensitive and sensual lover.
Which brings up a couple of questions: first...how can they tell that?
And second...is this really true?
Well, the headlines originated from a study found in the science journal Nature, all about
a new species of Tyrannosaurid called the
Daspletosaurus horneri.
It is a very long and complicated sounding paper full of long and complicated words that
covers everything from etymology to anagenesis.
But skimming over all that fun stuff, you’ll
find a section talking about evidence of small
openings on the Daspletosaurus’ snout and jaw.
These holes are the key to all that sensual
loving talk.
The study believes these holes were nerve openings.
They noticed they were identical in many ways to bumps called ISO’s found on the snouts
and jaws of modern day crocodiles.
These croc bumps are essentially touch sensors that make a crocodile’s face more sensitive
than human fingertips.
Crocs will rub these highly-sensitive areas
of their snout and jaw on the body or head
of their preferred partner in a pre-mating
ritual.
So, even though we don’t have direct proof that the T. Rex participated in similar mating
rituals, scientists can make the connection between the bumps on crocodile faces and the
holes on tyrannosaurid skulls, to deduce that they also rubbed each other down before sex.
The study also suggests the tyrannosaurids’ sensitive faces could have helped ensure proper
nest temperatures or to help them gently move eggs.
But, as we all know, sex sells, so that’s
what the media picked up on.
Cause you were never going to click on this headline.
But you might have clicked on something that suggests this:
That’s graphic.
Way more graphic than I thought it was going to be.
So you know how an asteroid is supposedly what led to the dinosaurs going extinct?
Well, what if that’s not actually what happened?
Find out what’s up in this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe and make sure to keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.